the third friday of the muslim holy
month of ramadan and more violence at
the al-aqsa mosque compound palestinian
protesters some flying hamas flags and
chanting support for the armed group
threw stones at israeli forces they
fired rubber bullets and stun grenades
and in a first at the site dropped tear
gas from a drone dozens were reported
injured the israeli government has now
banned jews from accessing the site
known to them as the temple mount as in
past years until the end of ramadan west
bank palestinian women and men over 50
allowed through israeli checkpoints for
prayers but after weeks of violence and
years of growing concern among
palestinians about jewish prayer in the
courtyards this latest tension is not
yet over
there's no easing of restrictions it's a
lie
they only announced it in the media
outlets but in reality they banned women
and elderly people because they didn't
have permits
in gaza where there have been exchanges
of rocket fire and israeli airstrikes
this week the first in months there was
a hamas-led protest against israel's
actions
during the main prayer of the day
however the scene was memorable for the
numbers worshipping the muslim trust
that runs the site said 150 000 people
had come to pray at islam's third
holiest site and this wasn't the only
mass religious event in the old city
well this is the third friday of ramadan
you have muslim worshipers coming
through the old city alleyways towards
the al-aqsa mosque for friday prayers
but this is a rare event the confluence
of three festivals for the three
abrahamic faiths the jewish passover and
the orthodox christian easter as well
and so we have these good friday
processions coming through the old city
as well
groups of pilgrims many from overseas
making the most of post-pandemic travel
walking slowly along the via dolorosa
following jesus's path to what is now
the church of the holy sepulchre for our
soul you know is something very special
and
let's say this is the crown of our life
this rare synchronicity in the religious
calendar a reminder that for all the
ugliness of recent weeks this is a place
holy to jews muslims and christians
alike harry fawcett al jazeera occupied
east jerusalem